this man saw our conversation about his
large s in returning
a very important football
that uh
you know really didn't belong here
until it was handed to him by mike evans
mike evans catches touchdown number 600
of tom brady's career making tom the
only member
of such a club in the great sport of uh
professional football
and uh he had it and gave it back i said
good for you you both brockman and tj
said what what's the matter hey pump
your brakes everything's worth 500
thousand dollars why didn't i hold out
for more held out well he responded to
that he thanked me for
supporting him yeah you were on you're
on his side yes appreciate the defense
the defense on your show we're on the
same page i'm sure you've heard that tom
mike and the bucks are taking care of me
too i immediately then uh
i guess technically slid into his dms
right i dm'd him and said how'd you like
to come on the show and he said sure and
here he is the man who had tom brady's
600th touchdown pass football placed in
his hands by mike evans
and then he gave it back obviously for
some items and money that he received a
bitcoin
byron kennedy tampa bay buccaneer fan
here on the rich island show how are you
byron
i'm doing great rich how are you i am
better for talking to you sir i've got a
lot of questions for you
all right first of all
first of all good for you all right
that's not a question that's a
declarative good for you good for you
thank you uh have you been receiving a
lot of grief for giving this football
back for what you received
um not directly it's more comments that
i'm reading on uh different posts from
like the nfl and just everyone else
who's covering this no one's actually
reaching out to me and giving me grief
okay um all the people reaching out to
me are saying you did the right thing
okay so let's walk through here whose
seats were you in are those your seats
they are not uh those are my buddy
riley's seats um he has season tickets
there okay i was invited to this game
with them
glad i came so you were riley's plus one
in these seats and
walk me through
uh what happened you're just sitting
there cheering and mike evans decides to
give you a ball because you were wearing
13. is that what happened exactly yeah
exactly um
the bucks had a great drive they went
pretty much all the way down the field
um
then
yeah straight towards us um
they were on the
nine yard line and this looked like the
touchdown they threw it mike evans
caught it on about the one fought into
the end zone and then i just started
going crazy in the end zone um
hearing as loud as i could i looked
around was celebrating with the people
around me and as i look back down at the
field mike evans is gesturing to get my
attention sprinting at me he jumps up
into the stands hands me the ball i get
to flap his uh shoulder pads
screamed big mike
and then i got the ball okay at what
point did you realize
that he had handed you perhaps the most
valuable football rarest of footballs in
the history of professional football
when did that dawn on you because it
dawned on me right away that mike evans
had just handed that ball
to a fan and you're that fan when did it
dawn on you that you had pass
number 600 of tom brady's touchdown pass
throwing career
so it wasn't right away uh mike evans
and i were definitely on the same page
and
yeah he's i'm sure you've seen that
video of him on the sidelines and what
that was the ball
gave the ball
right so we were on the same page um and
then
i had told the story a bunch of times
and i couldn't put my finger on when i
realized that that was a 600th ball
um but there were some bears fans
sitting next to me and obviously
everyone around me wanted to take
pictures um but i kept putting the nfl
logo in the front when this guy was
taking pictures and he kept turning the
ball again and i put the logo back in
front and he goes no no i want the
number at the bottom the 138 to be
showing in this picture because that
shows that this is tom brady's 600
touchdown and i think that right then is
when i realized that it was his
600 touchdown
okay so a bears fan who had the sense
and also a sense of
wanting to uh i guess um
memorialize the fact that he was around
such a special football is where it
dawns on you that you are now in
possession of it what happened next
byron
um a couple minutes later someone from
the team came over a guy named tim i
don't know if he's one of the trainers
or if he works with tom i don't know
exactly what his role is right but he
came over and was saying uh
can we get that ball back uh this is an
important one um
and i told him him no a couple of times
ah he said we won it um i said maybe if
tom personally comes over and asks for
it i'll hand it to him
um that obviously didn't happen we kept
kind of going back and forth and he's
basically saying tom brady really wants
this football back
we can get you signed jerseys whatever
you want i'll get you another ball right
now
um
and i said all right you know what okay
tom brady can have it he
he's the only person who's ever thrown
600 touchdowns
um
i haven't even watched 600 touchdowns
much less thrown than myself
right he deserves this ball i'll give it
back to him okay
so
that happens and um what is it so when
did you have you received everything
that has been reported to
been given to you like a signed jersey
from brady and assigned football from
tom right no i haven't received anything
that i didn't get at the game so far uh
they immediately handed me a different
game ball okay uh someone from their
management came down and handed me a big
gift card to the team store
but they took my address and phone
number and name and all that stuff while
i was at the game
and
monday afternoon i got a call from
the bucks and they said we've been
talking about your non-stop this is what
we're going to get you
it was the
two signed brady jerseys one for me one
for my buddy that was part of those
negotiations you all saw going on okay i
wanted to get him something because
he was sitting next to it it's his
ticket you mean you're his plus one you
you should get him at least a plus 12
right jersey exactly all right um so i'm
getting those two uh tom brady signed
helmet
uh mike evans signed jersey and mike
evans signed cleats okay and two season
tickets for the rest of this season and
next season
so that is what the bucks decided to
give me um i think they're getting ready
to send it because i just received an
official letter on their letterhead and
all that stuff all right so they should
be sending that over pretty soon i
imagine okay where are the seats do you
know where they are
i don't yet uh i asked him he said i i
don't exactly know but i'm sure they're
going to be pretty good they're not
going to put you up in the 300 section
or anything
i mean
we got to we got to get close to
midfield at least i mean we got to get
somewhere near there but i don't know if
they've got those lying around you know
what i mean like there's exactly that's
probably all taken off those end zone
seats were nice
that's true i mean riley's got two
pretty good uh seats right there all
right i got byron kennedy here on the
rich eisen show he was the one who had
and then relinquished the tom brady uh
football when did you learn that you had
a bitcoin coming from tom how did that
come into your possession or has it not
yet
well it hasn't yet um i've been talking
with tom brady's management team and i'm
filling out some forms because i think
there's some tax implications i have to
okay i have to worry about all right all
right um but i imagine it would come
some point today
i learned about it because tom brady
posted on his instagram story saying
let's make a trade with uh that ftx
company that he's a part of and then he
posted on his twitter saying
uh hey ftx let's get this bot guy a
bitcoin and they immediately replied
done and done let's make a trade
so
that was a couple hours before monday
night football
and then tom brady obviously
told the nation about it when he
mentioned it on monday night football
too
huh
okay
now then
i guess this is the most important
question
you're engaged to be married correct
correct okay your fiance's name is what
bridgette okay
what does she
think about you giving this stuff up for
you know
shirts and jerseys and hats and stuff
like that what does she think about this
subject matter uh she thinks i did the
right thing her parents think i did the
right thing um
they all think i made the right move
okay
very good
all right so
uh all said and done um
you you you're feeling good about all
this byron i am and uh i don't know if
you had heard but mojo and uh gronk
also are chipping in and trying to help
me out too they're giving me some
they're part of a beyond protocol okay
another crypto and they're giving me a
good amount of that too okay all right
good things come to those who just cough
it up brockman you want to say something
i know you want to say something to this
guy earlier this week now he's right
here i've protected him
byron love all love
uh knowing that your fiance is on board
your family is on board and like tom and
gronk are kind of hooking you up in the
crypto game which i am also a part of i
will stand down
i will stand down and congratulate you
for what you did
well thank you
i mean at the time there was there was
no guarantee i was going to get anything
so i understand where you're all coming
from okay it's all starting to work out
well also it seemed like it was such a
whirlwind of how it happened i can't
imagine the emotions you were feeling
and then when it dawned on you that it
was the ball and then all of a sudden
this guy is trying to convince you to
just give it to him so i'm sure that was
a lot and you know your head was
probably a lot of [ __ ] you know foggy
but i think it all worked out in the end
all right so um
byron here's what i'm going to do here
because i'm a michigan man like tom
brady um i will give you um either a
rich eisen show mug or twenty dollars in
our our merchandise store
uh which is the cost of the mug so it's
up to you what do you what do you what
do you what do you think byron can i i'm
a i'm a big coffee drinker i would want
to drink a coffee
all right uh and plus certainly since if
i'm not mistaken you have just started
um
internal medicine residency correct in
in central florida there
ryan yeah uh just in st pete in tampa
okay
so you're gonna need a lot of late night
early morning uh jolts of the java so
let me let me provide you
with uh with the mug how's that sound
all right that sounds fantastic i
appreciate it oh rich yes let's go i was
talking to byron yesterday yes he shared
kind of the same thoughts we did about
the gift card from the team shop if you
want to okay
okay yeah we think we think we think uh
we should get a little bit more than a
thousand bucks from the bucks be honest
with you you know
what's what we think the team store
some i'm i'm i had a theory that that's
probably the biggest gift card that they
have
another one to give to me unless they
just started handing me a bunch of gift
cards i love it fantastic i feel like
they probably gave me the biggest gift
card that they have all right byron
kennedy thanks for the call man
congratulations on your 15 minutes of
fame and doing the right thing with it i
thought you did the right thing man
thank you i appreciate it thank you for
having me you bet that's byron kennedy
right here
on the rich eisen show
that was great
seems like a great guy i think so too
yeah hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here